Romeo France is running for a seat in
Germany's Parliament the Bundestag to
work for the interests of his ethnic
group visente but then he'll have less
time to play the scentee swing music
he's loved since childhood these mosaic
is my lame see this music is my life
keep me cuffed it sustains me and gives
me strength I've always used my music as
a means of mediation between the
majority and the minority session damia
Hyatt on the moon diet this feeling of
being part of an unaccepted minority
being called as a goner or gypsy being
regarded as an immigrant from Eastern
Europe even though the family has been
in Germany for 600 years for once Romeo
France wants to say out loud who he is
in the Bundestag for the Green Party
France wants to represent ludwigshafen
after years with the scentee Association
he concluded it doesn't have enough
influence so he joined the Greens three
years ago and went into politics the
party leaders welcomed him but the
rank-and-file wonder will he care about
anything beyond the country's 60,000
Cindy he's a problematic garbage this
issue has been discussed but mostly at
the beginning of his candidacy ins and
later at no longer played a role Romeo
is not someone working just for the sin
T he's interested in everything but of
course justice and integration are his
focus essentially approved his top a
stroll along the Rhine River Romeo
France estimates his chances at 50 50 if
he wins he'll be the first-ever sinto
member of the Bundestag he's fourth
greens because of their work for
minorities shobhit indecent in these
alongside the bleep I'd feel up in this
period working for civil rights I
gathered a lot of experience with the
parties and none was as close to me as
the Greens so it didn't take long for me
to decide which party to join it was
definitely going to be the Greens a
baton vietti heather tesch from 14th i
wanted to work with them 10 or 12 years
ago about dhamma as well but back then
the scentee organizations didn't want
members identifying themselves with
specific parties pop hi poli dishes for
many the rhine epitomizes germany Romeo
France loves its tranquility he calls
himself a Prussian sinto but in the Nazi
period Germany was also the country that
murdered half a million Sinti and Roma
including six members of the France
family
berlin's Mitte district a monument was
recently unveiled to commemorate the
murdered Sinti and Roma a violin melody
composed by Romeo France assist us me
team ethnic as simple as a sinto I can
identify with an old key that's nice and
I assume that a center or Roma standing
at this monument and hearing this melody
will recognize what it means that it's
very important to me because it's a
memorial to the Sinti and Roma and it
should be imbued with enough soul that
you can recognize yourself in it death
onesie film Vita akin kaya ludwigshafen
himself district is home to many
minorities senti Roma and Muslims many
are unemployed or have low paying jobs
many people in the city regard the Roma
moving here from Bulgaria and Romania as
a problem but not Romeo France on down
through von der Anita it's fine we
mustn't regard immigrants as enemies but
as friends and as an opportunity to
renew Germany and its social welfare
systems these alliances t minus 15 but
this is really important and that's why
if I'm elected to the Bundestag my
interest will be in addressing these
issues he'll have his work cut out for
him Sinti and Roma often live on the
margins of society only three percent of
them attend college prep high school
being their advocate will be a difficult
task before the elections Romeo France
wants to play lots of concerts with his
band and his special violin bow these
are bogus I in fetch Naboo this is a
fetch neighborhood but it's I it is not
surmise what city's most my grandfather
managed to rescue it through the Nazi
period in Swat it belonged to my
grandfather's brother imposed on all
fronts and I ultimately inherited it
well being some frisky out Romeo's
great-uncle Powell France was murdered
in Auschwitz
Romeo's band wishes him lock in the
elections but he been goodish but that
would mean the end of the band because
Romney I wouldn't have time anymore
Quinn blog about whom you'll feel a kind
of sight now applause for the musician
still the politician wants to perform on
another stage starting in november the
newly elected bundestag